una invasión rusa en ucrania que podría
ocurrir en cualquier momento
desencadenando un conflicto militar en
europa es el temor de occidente
expresado este viernes por el secretario
de estado de eeuu anthony blinken quien
además apuntó a las posibles
consecuencias si se produce este
escenario que hemos estado elaborando
exactamente lo que implicarían esas
consecuencias incluyendo sanciones
económicas y financieras controles de
exportación por su parte el kremlin
continúa negando toda intención de
invadir ucrania en una entrevista con
france 24 al representante ruso en
europa alegó estar plenamente
comprometido con el diálogo diplomático
sobre ucrania y restó importancia al
despliegue de barcos de la marina rusa
en el mar negro que cuenta con casi
10.000 soldados
a fleet de einstein nuestras flotas
participan en grandes ejercicios esto no
tiene nada que ver con ucrania
understand nothing pero nada que pueda
considerarse una amenaza ni para ucrania
ni para ningún otro país vecino
me encanta la semana estuvo marcada por
distintas reuniones de alto nivel en
búsqueda de una salida diplomática
urgente este viernes la alta tensión
motivó a eeuu reino unido israel a pedir
la evacuación de sus ciudadanos y
personal diplomático en kiev el
secretario general de la otan también se
refirió al tema
a
la combinación de acumulación militar
retórica y un historial de uso de la
fuerza contra los vecinos por supuesto
es motivo para estar seriamente
preocupados estar atentos y listos para
reaccionar si vuelven a usar la fuerza
contra ucrania
mientras los esfuerzos diplomáticos para
desescalar las tensiones continúan del
mismo modo que las maniobras militares
de ambos países